what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are concluding infinity where
we're finally wrapping the story up and
and god I love infinity so much you know
what I might do what we've done with
like blackest night and brightest day or
like kind of stuff and just like combine
this into one big video I think it's a
cool idea because I know there are some
of you guys who were just kind of like I
want to see like the whole thing in its
entirety so I do kind of like I think we
might start doing that from now on like
whenever we do like videos where were
things are like split into sections and
then combine it into one big video like
once we're done but the cool thing about
this is we basically pick up with the
Avengers coming from space and showing
back up on earth with all these groups
showing up here having allied themselves
and coordinated themselves with Captain
America arriving on earth for the most
part there's two battles that take place
one of them is out in space and the
other one is basically trying to like
punch a hole for Captain America and his
guys to get through and that's what
happens Captain America and his forces
are really like Thor and Hyperion
Incredible Hulk Carol Danvers the Oh
Captain Marvel Captain America they
basically finally managed to make their
way back to earth and when they do it's
okay we have to organize this now in
truth with the way that Jonathan Hickman
wrote this you could have like the
guardians of the galaxy who arrive and
like all the forces of Thanos are
destroyed but remember when it comes to
the planet Earth it's an Avengers world
it's a place where like the Avengers
keep the place taken care of because
this is basically just the story of the
Avengers versus Thanos and that's what
it boils down to but it's kind of
fighting for the protection of Earth
which is cool now of course we The
Incredible Hulk being here you gotta
bring out your big guns right I mean
you're talking about Thanos it's
something that you kind of have to you
kind of have to do it and it's cool
because one thing to bear in mind is
that in Marvel Comics Thanos has kind of
like a not really a fear of the
Incredible Hulk but recognizes the
dangers of the whole we saw that in the
Thanos vs. Hulk story where were Thanos
to basically said look like I've always
avoided fighting the Incredible Hulk
because his strength is limitless and so
when it comes to the Hulk as a character
he's one of those guys where if you
don't have the ability to like take him
out immediately like as soon as the Hulk
emerges he'll just keep getting angrier
and angrier and eventually we'll just
overpower you it's just kind of how the
character works and so Captain America
immediately sends him out and says get
out there do your thing be a distraction
tear up as much stuff as you possibly
can now the other half of this is we
have the Illuminati right like Black
Panther and Doctor Strange and Reed
Richards and Ironman and so on name of
the Submariner and they're all basically
here at that Acropolis in Wakanda
the city of the Dead in order to try to
find a way to stop a bomb from being the
act are being activated by supergiant
the issue is that when they get there
the bombs already set in motion has
already been activated it's just waiting
for a trigger but supergiant has also
seized control of Blackpool now remember
we talked about this before right like
old-school Black Bolt from like the 70s
and 80s his voice could shatter planets
his power has been reduced over time now
in terms of how Marvel justifies this in
the modern day
what do you basically say is like the
detonation of the terrigen bomb helped
to reduce the powers of Black Bolt
exactly how I don't think is really
specified but basically that's kind of
the art the explanation that's offer the
sort of scenario that's given here but
the long and short of it is that for the
most part like the armor of Tony Stark
and Doctor Strange the various you know
capabilities they have they can for the
most part withstand the full might of
black bolts voice these would be totally
destroyed but because of the fact of the
armor of Tony Stark gives him really
enhanced durability in a lot of
different ways Doctor Strange can use
whatever spells he needs to you and then
with a submariner it's just highly
durable because of the fact that he's
basically a mutant Atlantean and mutant
hybrid what this means is that beast is
really the only one who wouldn't who
wouldn't stand much of a chance and so
of course you have Namor push beasts out
of the way and that is really really
cool here because dr. strange sort of
chimes in and Doctor Strange basically
says look like you guys have pushed us
to the break time and time again wanting
to see what happens wanting to see how
far we fall so if what you want to see
is oblivion if what you want to see is
the abyss then allow me to oblige allow
me as the sorcerer supreme to bring to
life your worst nightmares and so what
we end up doing is jumping directly to
the inhuman Royal City of all wrong we
pick back up with Thanos
and this is cool because Thanos being
here with what's left of the black order
meaning that like black dwarf pitch
basically been defeated he's pretty much
out of the picture and then you've got
supergiant with the Illuminati all you
really have left here is Proxima
midnight Corvus glaive the ebony maw and
of course stay in the son of Thanos
who's held in stasis but it's cool
because they don't start to talk about
how life is sort of meaningless and the
usual rigmarole that he usually you know
that he goes through and then suddenly
they met with the arrival of the
Incredible Hulk
now if Thanos punches the Hulk out of
the way but keep in mind then and notice
this Thanos does not immediately jump
into battle with the Incredible Hulk and
again there's a reason for this
he sends Corvus glaive and he sends
Proxima midnight to deal with the Hulk
because for the most part they can hold
their own against against the Hulk
himself and this comes my way the fact
about the various powers that they have
especially Proxima midnight using her
ability
to force him back into his Bruce Banner
form what this means is it leaves the
field open for Thanos to deal with
whatever comes next and what comes next
is Captain America
Hyperion Thor and Captain Marvel Carol
Danvers now in the crop allah switching
back over to the necropolis of dr.
strange what we end up finding out is
that he actually starts to bring out Shu
McGrath not completely but partially the
Shu McGrath is an interesting concept
and we've never really talked about him
before we have insofar as like the many
angled ones but like Shu McGrath was
actually yanked out of his native
dimension by dr. strange and brought
into the main Marvel Universe as part of
infinity we didn't cover that section of
the story because there's a small set of
events that takes place with like Luke
cages Mighty Avengers but that's really
about it but it is cool because human
grass is far less powerful in the main
Marvel Universe than he is in his native
dimension and it's even hypothesize
depending on what story you're talking
about that like Shu McGrath can never
actually be defeated and like Galactus
Shu McGrath appears to any given race
based on how that race would perceive
him so it's kind of an interesting thing
but still it is cool because ultimately
you have like Reed Richards who sort of
uses his powers to stretch and kind of
intervenes and starts binding in and
basically separates Black Bolt from from
super giant who's just mentally
controlling Black Bolt himself and so
from there it's kind of cool because
what we end up getting is like like
Black Panther sort of trying to speak to
super Jai and say look you're wasting
your time here like this is preposterous
I don't know why you're trying to set
this bomb off because you're gonna
destroy everything and everyone but like
your goals and your schemes won't really
come to fruition like you're gonna kill
yourself here you know and that's what
that's again the theme is constantly hit
on when it comes to the black order
something else said I want to hit on to
you because somebody mentioned this in a
comment in the last video in the in the
movie infinity war black dwarf is
actually gonna be called a call obsidian
like like Marvel changed his name for
the movie the Cole obsidian is the name
of the black quarter Thanos calls the
black order they call obsidian the black
order call themselves the black order
because they think it sounds cooler but
still like like the black order like
they desire death you know every single
member of the black order the Thanos
appear to especially here with
supergiant was at a moment in their life
when they crave death when they
basically wanted to die and Thanos his
response was I will give you what you
wish I will give you death but you will
have to fulfill a task for me first
that's how he works because Robert
Thanos has an affection for mistress
death he loves the idea of death he's a
nihilist and so the result is that when
these various people were in this point
he just kind of used that as a way to
this guy
shanghaied them into his own order and
then in turn they carry out his schemes
in the hopes that he will free them from
life so to speak now again it's cool
because switching back over to Iran this
is when you really start to get like
into the nitty-gritty of the ebony MA
and this is why I love the ebony maw so
much not just because of the fact that
like the name is amazing dude I love the
name he evany ma like I love that name
so much it is so cool but it's also
because like like look at the things he
says see this is why the ebony ma is so
awesome no real powers to speak of but
like look at the things he says I mean
basically talking to Thane it's like
look at what you're watching here you're
watching the Earth's Avengers the
Earth's superheroes fighting off against
the cull obsidian and sure they might
defeat the coal obsidian and in fact for
the most part they do but you have like
some of the most powerful beings in the
universe Carol Danvers Captain Marvel
Thor The Incredible Hulk Captain America
you have some of the greatest heroes in
the history of the planet Earth and even
some of the greatest heroes across the
universe and what they're doing is
getting rekt why because there's two
kinds of people in the universe those
who know that with Thanos comes death
and those who are so foolish to believe
that if they pray to the sky to a god
that's up there listening that maybe
that God will spare them from the wrath
of a Titan of Thanos his caliber maybe
they'll be safe but they're foolish for
believing so with Thanos
comes death death is always there to
follow only a fool believes they stand a
chance in the in the face of Thanos
might and that's what's so cool about
this because like it's what we would
expect like what you're seeing here with
Thanos just like juicing all over earth
superheroes that's gonna be infinity war
firfer the earth superheroes it's it's
the end of times for Thanos it's a
Tuesday like it's not a huge deal it's
just kind of like whatever man you know
this is what I do I destroy things
so like either you can just be one of
the many people I've killed or you can
get out of my way but that's what we
would expect
now again something else that takes
place is kind of cool dealing with like
super giant she's kind of whisked out of
the picture pretty fast
you have heard hunting for the trigger
more or less and then Maximus the mat
appears brother a bag of black bull now
Maximus the mad is kind of interesting
because he's an on-again-off-again
villain he's one of those characters
where he does whatever he needs to do to
satisfy his own end so think of him as
like an inhuman version of Loki in a lot
of ways and because of this when he
appears to two super giant he has a
trigger in his hand and says look if you
do what I ask then I'll give you this
trigger I'll give you whatever you know
I'll give you what it is that you seek
and the response is okay like like what
are you you know what do you look
for and what he says is the same is the
same thing I always want to basically be
the smartest person in the room that's
the only thing I ever really want and
I'm proving that now because you forgot
about the most dangerous thing in the
room and so what ends up happening is he
basically triggers the bomb and in the
moment when the bomb is triggered locked
jaw the teleporting dog teleports the
bomb and super giant away and then
teleports back and super giant gets
blown to pieces it's so cool and it's so
smart like it's pretty funny but super
giant of courses is ultimately destroyed
but again transitioning back to like to
Thames with the Illuminati and all those
forces showing you know intending to
show back up to where Captain America is
to help in the fight with Thanos with
the ebony ma talking to Thane again it's
so cool and this is what I love so much
about this is it's basically like look
only a fool would believe they have a
chance to live against a being of
afghanistan's caliber who worships death
with Thanos comes death it's an absolute
rule of the universe but when you end up
having a Proxima midnight who of course
throws her various weapons at Captain
America with Captain America shield
being powered by freedom actually
because of the fact that it's so durable
with you know being kind of a adamantium
iron vibranium alloy of course the
energy signatures basically dissipate
and one of them hits Corvus glaive and
so Corvus glaive is essentially
incinerated in his entirety by an
additional attack that comes from
Hyperion now this is something to
remember about Corvus glaive for those
of you guys who have seen my recent
videos with Marvel now 2.0 in Thanos vol
1 right off the bat you're probably
asking yourself the question if Corvus
glaive is destroyed here then how did he
show up a Marvel now to point out
okay so Corvus glaive if you notice
always carries a staff so long is that
staff is never broken an intact Corvus
glaive can never truly be destroyed his
essence will live on and he'll just be
reconstructed that's kind of how that
works and so as a result you suddenly
have like what's left of the superheroes
facing off against against Thanos and
that's that's what's cool because you
suddenly have like Thor who jumps into
the fray and it's interesting because
like you look at this and you're like oh
yeah man Thor Thor is calling down the
lightning because you know god of
thunder and all that cool stuff Thor's
got this man right wrong like Thor gets
wrecked like it's amazing Thor gets
crushed so bad it's it's hilarious this
is Thanos we're talking about and just
as like a base form no Cosmic Cube no
power stone no Infinity Gauntlet no none
of that stuff he's more than a match for
the
Earth's superheroes and where Thor comes
riding in hi nothing happens like
Dan'l's just beats the crap out of him
and that's that's that's the cool thing
to take away from here because the whole
time this is taking place the ebony ma
is whispering in the ear of Thane this
is how he works this is how he functions
duplicity manipulation this is how he
makes a name for himself the ebony ma is
looking at Thane and saying look upon my
works and frown because only oblivion
waits those who were so foolish as to
believe they have a chance to succeed
against Thanos but if someone doesn't
step in they're all going to die and so
this is your opportunity thing this is
your chance are you going to run from
the idea of being the son of Thanos are
you going to take off from your destiny
are you gonna run and hide in the hills
or are you going to actually do
something are you going to become the
son of Thanos and that's exactly what
Thane does he finally steps up and says
yes and basically uses hand uses uh uses
his right hand I think it has to
essentially encase Thanos and living
death to basically encase him in amber
and he'll never be able to escape
Proxima midnight is in the exact same
situation
they're basically stuck here now this
goes forward into the future of Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers and
time runs out storyline and eventually
they are free that's where the Cabal of
name where the Submariner comes from and
that's why you see a nose in the future
of Avengers of New Avengers and going
into like Secret Wars and the collapse
of the multiverse but that's what this
is designed to do it's designed to
basically take the power in do take
Thanos as a character and put him on the
back burner so that hickman can come
back and return him and have him
continue on when the rest of the
Avengers of New Avengers story from here
it's just kind of like rebuilding right
is Captain America and it's Hyperion and
Carol Danvers and all these folks
basically rebuilding it's the world
coming to grips of the fact that like
Inhumans are rising in a prominence now
it's the other universes across the
cosmos recovery rebuilding their
respective empires and all that kind of
good stuff but for the Illuminati for
name with a submariner fervor for Iron
Man for Reed Richards of the Fantastic
Four for beast for black panther for
Doctor Strange the collapse of the
multiverse continues on the incursions
continue on and while Thanos has been
defeated he's just one small conflict
the rest of everything is still going to
continue on you're still gonna have the
collapse of the multiverse you're still
gonna have the incursions not only that
where they basically face off against
Thanos in this regard and they've had to
like focus on the idea of presumably
facing their own mortality
what they've also got to contend with is
other universes now they've got to
contend with the black priests the
ivory kings all this stuff that goes
into like the collapse of the multiverse
and the end of all things but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain and make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace